today is the day people all right what
are we watching fear I don't think you
could handle this I'm not scared of
everything all right here it is finally
hey ho are you kidding me out of the
dates buffering makes me sad and we're
back
who are you I'm fear you're not talking
to us ah I know 100 what is it I was
raised to do one thing I've got nothing
to fight for
whoa this place is huge the beach
oh so stressful nothing will stand in
our way
finish what the heck is that what you
started
there are stories about what happened
it's true
yeah we want to be friends with them
okay so I'm breaking out
I love this trailer yeah it's pretty
cool Thank You captain obvious
the dark side
this is a rollercoaster of emotions Jedi
let's heat things up
they're real
the force it's calling to you
girl easy easy
[ __ ] ooh just editing I'm doing the
happy dance I'm not wearing any pants
I think I'm over stimulated wait what
December if they just say we have to
wait that's a long long long way